Yeah.
Well the problem is that what defines risk is often defined by her behavior.
The least risky thing is what everyone is doing.
Like if you're in a hurry,
that's certainly the case.
The least risky thing is to be in the middle of what everyone else in the herd
is doing.
Creditors can't pick you off there and people act like that all the time.
And so,
you know,
we'll stock market investment like Michael Risky when hardly anyone is doing it
because the way that your brain is judging risk is by the number of people doing
it.
But as soon as everyone's doing it,
the risky thing is to be left behind because if you're left behind,
predators will get you your the straggling sheet.
And so what that means is the definition of what constitutes conservative
changes as mass behavior changes.
So,
so it isn't even obvious how to advise people as to what the conservative path
is.
Now,
you know,
standard economic adviser would say diversify.
Well,
yeah,
I'll tell you in the 2008 crash,
you could have diversified your money across multiple markets all over the
world.
Wouldn't help you damn bed,
everything came down.
So yeah,
you can diversify,
but that increases your transaction costs and you have to have quite a bit of
money to do it and you have to have quite a bit of knowledge.
And so it,
the thing is it's not that easy to make a pile of grain lapsed and that's what
we're always trying to do.
You know,
it did.
This disappears of its own accord.
It deteriorates.
Money does that with inflation.
People are always trying to nibble away at it,
you know?
And then now and then there's an earthquake and all the green disappears into
the ground.
It's hard to preserve value across time.
And you could say that about your body
there.
It's valuable.
Well in the natural state,
wolves would be after it,
you know,
it's hard to preserve value across time and how you do that.
There's no sure fire way of doing it,
conservative way of doing it that can fail,
a risky way of doing it that can succeed.
It also depends on what you mean by success too.
Because to judge whether someone's a winner or loser means you have to set a
priority standards by which to judge them.
And that is not simple.
You know,
in our culture where people love celebrities,
they,
I'd love to be a celebrity.
Well,
sure,
that's what you think.
But Marilyn Monroe's,
it wasn't served well by,
it doesn't really look like Elvis was,
um,
you know,
there's a long list of collapsing celebrities.
So were they successful?
Not by the standards of reasonable longevity.
They were the,
they were successful by Neil young standards.
Right.
Better to burn out than to fade away.
Okay.
Maybe,
you know,
maybe it's better to burn bright longer,
but it's arguable,
you know.